yesterday afternoon I don't know if you
heard me mention it it sort of was a bit
of a side comment and then I thought
about a little bit more and I thought no
actually it's just something with hoping
you know there's been a lot of time we
can't triangles now it's a very natural
question to ask but wait am I going Who
am I gonna do this
okay and the answer is kind of all the
time and kind of never let me explain
this is trigonometry trigonometry the
word trigonometry kind of tells you what
it's about when you've got something
with a metric on the unlike optometry or
geometry right does anyone know what
that metree bit on the air means I gave
you a bit of a clue there's another word
we have a think I heard another word we
have which is the same root right which
we use for our system of course talk
about centimeters and meters and what's
that system it's the metric system which
another way of saying measurement now
measurements one part of bats it's not
the only one now have a look at the
front of the word try gone boom what
does try me and gone means angle which
is why when we talk about polygons poly
means many so polygons are just anything
with lots of angles so in this time what
I want to do is I want to gather
together all of what we know so far it's
not complete yet but I'll give you an
idea of how everything we know fits
together at the moment we've been
dealing with two main kinds of trails
the first ones where you have right
angles
now I've already drawn one of these
triangles on the board I've been very
careful what to call them grinding the
triangles because that's writing the
triangle but here's a triangle that's
not right angled right but if I put a
right angle in it like say this and if
you know that length say for instance
you actually know a lot more about this
triangle because of that right angle
even though the corners none of them
writings so if you have right angles at
all for instance we know how to find
area right if you've got some right
angles there if you know sir angles the
area is really easy to get what's the
formula 1/2 base times height very good
okay but what we've been trying to do is
expand with tree because that doesn't
have any trig in it where you don't have
my language
last week we realized through a bit of
construction and mucking around that
even if you don't have a right angle in
your triangle anywhere at all we
developed a new formula for finding the
area do you remember what it is it
starts with a half maybe very good and
in fact that B sine C is really just a
fight you just have to work it out we
treat all right but we actually know a
lot more about triangles and how to work
things out for instance if you've got a
triangle with right angles in it and
what you want is to find side lengths if
you've got a right angle triangle like
this and I gave you some lengths like
this and this if you had right angles
and you wanted to find side lights what
would you do to this thing
Pythagoras right which is what is hey
squared
what's this way so we would use we would
appeal to Pythagoras
but now we've learned you can actually
find side lengths even when you don't
have a right angle triangle yesterday we
introduced this side new thing that's
we're on a heading and there were two
ways to write the same rule if what you
want to find is side lengths and the
first thing I'm going to write is a side
length like this they don't I just like
over here right if the length I'm trying
to find so if I divide that by sign a
because it is the sine rule after all
that should be equal to the on side B
and that also equals to I've an
understatement
it's also equal to C on the sign C
however usually you don't need to use
all three of them even though that's
true you only need to use two of them
and then you can make an equation now
the last thing we've got you
is if you don't what area or if you know
what Silas is one other thing you can
measure in a triangle and it is you can
trim it up but it comes from the side
length right okay now again remember
let's have a look at this guy up here
see this triangle here it's wide angle
because it's right angle you can find
out any of the angles you want inside
that triangle and what would you use
again you'd use yeah soccer Thomas we've
had let's just write that up here
sohcahtoa more example in this triangle
up here if I call the deduce angle in
the corner clean up you've got a 17 or
24 what ratio would you use young you
just ten because it's opposite adjacent
so you'd say ten theta equals seven on
24 in other words you're using the
trigonometric ratios in their original
intended form okay but then we learnt
yesterday again this sign rule that we
prove that we created we can use it for
angles as well what do you do is take
this thing and turn it upside down just
flip it upside down and you have for
example sign a on a it's the same
formula but if you flip it upside down
suddenly you have changed subject and
now it's much easier to find angles you
just sort of save yourself a step now
this table is not quite complete we're
almost there but I want you to
understand this is how
all fits together and you learn all of
this stuff you've added on this fairly
recently and then really really recently
we've put this in place as well okay so
I know it starts to become a bit wide
load I know so much talk about triangles
and get mixed up
I hope this table will help you
understand where you can use it so how
do we use this have a look first
based on our table right what are you
being asked to find what's the unknown
it's a link fantastic so when I look at
my scheme and all this knowledge and I
know I can see if this is where I'm
gonna go first okay this is what I'm
after I can use this to help me here but
you remember this and is Eames being
this beam they're they're intentionally
they're not they're coincidentally right
why is that important which one is
matched up with which okay so this is
the one where it's not so much about the
included angle which was this one it's
about the opposite angles right so for
example you want to find X okay which
angle is it opposite yeah I I actually
don't know what this angle is it's over
here and that's really important and
what a students will look at this you
know saying two angles two sides I'll
just put them into the formula because I
can see them right but you can actually
notice there's something additional I
have to find out can you talk about that
angle is yeah very good so 34 plus 53 is
87 87 so if you subtract 87 from 180
you'll get 93
now I have the information I need to
that to be other length is opposite
disabled okay so I've identified
everything I need
what am I going to write what's the
first thing I'm gonna like the thing I
want first X on yeah very good sir I had
to find this angle and then it's equal
to the other parry yeah very good
fantastic you're starting to get the
rhythm of this right you can see by the
way do you remember what I told you
about bearings questions I gave you some
principles of bearings questions one of
the principles was read the question
carefully if you don't read it carefully
you don't know what you're looking for
and then you don't know what to use and
then secondly the other hint was draw a
diagram I know they give you diagrams
but do you see how much I relied on my
diagram to actually saw this accurately
like I had to put constructions on a
draw order so I made sure that I match
things up correctly can we find out what
the answer is
okay let's get a number um can I get one
decimal place please 16.4 can I get some
agreement on that yeah calculator should
that work for last thing before we leave
cents check cents check now remember I
told you with these you can do like a
regular sense check and say oh this
number is in the ballpark but you can do
an even better sense check by looking at
this number and comparing it to this one
sixteen point four if you guys if you
guys are in the AP threes and I'm
looking around I see some of you in the
middle you def going like this to it
just to make it aa quick hey just to
make sure
does it make sense look you've gone this
side opposite a small angle and you've
got this side opposite a bigger angle is
that what you expected yeah